hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the associated topics that
Aristotle discusses in categories
chapter 10 which has to do with
opposition is how and whether opposites
can change into each other now in the
course of his discussion he really only
explicitly treats two of the four main
types of opposite that is contraries
patent on TIA in Greek and then
positives and privations hexes and store
ASIS but we could also ask and I will do
this toward the end wait a second what
about core relatives you know terms that
are relational to each other and what
about affirmation and denial would this
fit into that at all so before we do
that let's note one very important
distinction Aristotle is going to say
that with contraries you can actually
have change and it can go back and forth
in either direction with positives and
privet primitives you can also have
change but it only goes in one direction
so we'll talk about why that's the case
in just a moment now let's think about
contraries themselves tanaan TIA
examples of these are some of the ones
that we have on the board healthy versus
sick right Aristotle says either you're
healthy or you're sick it's one of those
that doesn't have intermediaries for
Aristotle white and black for this there
are a whole bunch of intermediaries
namely the other colors good and bad
there is an intermediary for that namely
being neither good nor bad he also talks
about cold and hot so with that in mind
what does Aristotle says he says with
contraries they can change into each
other
so the Greek for that is East Aleya
Mata bullet met the Boleyn ganash Snyder
literally there can occur a change in
into the the opposites right and you
could say well what is a
actually changing our opposites changing
into each other this is actually a
classic problem that was raised by put
by Aristotle's teacher Plato already in
some of his dialogues and then treated
by aerosol at much greater lengths in
works like say for example the
metaphysics here Aristotle is going to
give you sort of a thumbnail sketch of
that he says the subject the group will
came in on though the thing in which the
quality is that remains the same but one
thing is exchanged for another one thing
is coming in another thing is going out
you might say so what would be an
example of that okay so here's a book a
book is a Hoople came in on a subject
let's assume that this is green
hopefully you know you don't have
red-green color blindness and you can
see that this is green but let's say I
decide that I do want to dye it red so
we go to the whoever does that sort of
thing and we dip it into the you know
the dye and now all the covering the
cloth is red actually the Hoople kheema
known technically in this case is not
the book itself but rather the cloth
that comprises the covering of the book
cover itself so we change it the
underlying thing has remained the same
but we have provided it with a different
quality and we can talk about hot and
cold in the same way we can talk about
goodness badness in the same way there's
a lot of things along these lines so we
do in fact have change but something
remains the same in it now Aristotle
says that there are some cases where you
can't actually change things that way
whereas he says the conch one contrary
is part of that subject so he's given
examples like this in the past of you
know snow and coldness you're not going
to have a hot snow I mean we we do have
a word for that water vapor right so
it's no longer the same
thing we could say well the water itself
can be hot or cold right
but as snow it cannot and Aristotle also
says at another point that look snow is
is white it doesn't make sense to talk
about black snow or yellow snow or red
snow and you might say well wait a
second what if we you know put some food
coloring in it right as people do well
then you're adding food coloring to the
snow you're not changing the snow itself
you're just adding something you might
say on top of it right so Aristotle goes
on and he says there's other things too
like fire and hotness you're not going
to be able to heat it constitutes part
of what it is to be fire right in other
cases we can change things so he gives
four examples I put three of them on the
board we might think of other examples
using other contraries that he brings up
you can go from being healthy to being
sick I mean some of us experience this
multiple times in a year we understand
what that is like right you're healthy
for a while and then you catch cold or
you know you have an allergic reaction
or something bad happens to you and now
you're sick white can go to black black
is the contrary of white good and bad
Aristotle has very interesting
discussion here
he says the bad man once introduced two
new modes of both of living and thinking
may improve his how we go back from bad
to good right be it ever so little and
then he says and should a man once
improve even though it be only a little
he might it is clear make great progress
or even indeed change entirely for ever
more easily moved and inclined as a man
towards virtue even though in that very
first instance he made very little
improvement we naturally therefore
concluded will make ever greater advance
and if the process continues it will at
length change him entirely provided time
is allowed so Aristotle thinks there's a
huge difference between the bad person
and the good
and that over time you know we can we
can move there now notice that with the
good and the bad there is a there is a
middle state right are actually probably
a whole set of middle states in between
and we don't go from good to bad
immediately but we we do it you know by
stages and likewise when we go from bad
to good it doesn't work that way this is
very important to think about when
people do bad things as good people and
they say it's not really going to affect
me or so say well I could affect you
much but keep it up and you will indeed
go from good to bad the good news is
however you can also come back from bad
to good likewise with colors there's a
whole bunch of different possibilities
you know we have the greyscale Aristotle
talks about the other colors as being in
between white and black and you know if
you think about light mechanics I
suppose that that's quite true
you know there's a whole spectrum of the
rainbow and you can you can go from you
know you can make something that that's
black B White's provided it's not an
integral part of the very nature of the
thing and vice-versa right
same thing with going back from sickness
to health if you're healthy and you
become sick it's not the end of the
world depending on what the sickness is
because you can go from being sick to
being healthy so there is this back and
forth possibility the subject is
remaining the same except insofar as the
subject has contrary qualities that it
is taking on what about positives and
primitives here's where Aristotle says
something quite interesting that we
might find a bit contestable in our own
time he says we only go one direction
with these you you can't go in both
directions you start out with the
possession and then you wind up with the
privet --iv and once you've got the
privet of once you've you're lacking and
natural capacity or lacking something
that should be there you can't get it
back what are his examples very
interesting example
lose your sight you're blind now that's
a primitive you're not getting that
sight back if you go bald you're not
getting your hair back if you lose your
teeth you're not getting those back now
this is interesting isn't it because we
we are now getting close to the point
where people who have lost their sight
sometimes are getting their sight
restored through some extraordinary
medical measures and I suppose you know
we tend to look at it as a as kind of a
routine thing now you know how to deal
with hair loss there's hair replacement
surgery and people get all sorts of
other interesting things there's creams
you can rub on your head that apparently
will help you grow hair
hopefully it'll put them on other places
and have all sorts of extra hair is
growing which tends to be one of the
problems with these sorts of products so
it does look like we could get those
things back teeth well you got the teeth
that your jaw came with if you ever
looked at x-rays of like infants things
it's kind of gross looking because
there's all those extra teeth in there
right we can replace teeth but we can't
really regrow teeth at least at this
point so perhaps you know from the
perspective of modern medicine we might
say and technology you might say layer
so perhaps is wrong about that but for
the most part you're not going to get
back those things unless there's some
extraordinarily complex intervention so
perhaps he's also right about this now
there's there's one other things say
about privet is that Aristotle himself
didn't go into there is an important all
another type of change before possession
and privat of becomes an issue then
there's a state prior to that and for
example having a beard you know this is
a famous one for the ancients should a
boy have a beard no and it's not a
privation for a boy not to have a beard
because a boy doesn't
we have a beard I mean actually one of
the ways to divide boy from from you
know young man is the capacity to grow
up here okay and so once now if you're
if you're from a culture that thinks
that beards are really the thing which
some ancient cultures were then they
would say well not having a beard is
actually predation and having a beard is
the positive this is the one where you
can change quite easily though right
shave it off grow it back shave it off
grow up back
what about rationality we don't expect
children Aristotle says in other places
to be rational because that capacity
that that part of the soul is not yet
developed in them however once they've
reached the age of reason to lack that
would in fact be a privation of stare
ASIS and so there's a change that goes
on from the state where there's neither
privation nor positive to a state where
there either is privation or positive I
mentioned that we could also ask about
the other two forms of opposition
correlatives
chemical relatives change into each
other and the answer to that is yes and
no I mean can double and half become
switched around well only if the
underlying things that they're measuring
change themselves and then it's going to
change in double in half it's a change
in those things isn't it what about
father and son can't a son become a
father
yes but he's not a father to the same
being in which he existed as a son in
relation to a father he is existing in
relation to another being so there is
change taking place there in a way but
it's not the kind of change that we're
talking about here what about
affirmation and denial
can'tcan't sentences change in their
truth value yes they can but that's a
different sort of issue and we're
dealing with that in some other
discussions
so that one doesn't get discussed here
in terms of change because it's not this
sort of thing where one thing is turning
into its opposite turning into the other